you want a little update on space wars
well North Korea says that they just
took a picture of the White House with
their new spy satellite it took them
three tries but North Korea eventually
got a successful launch of a spy
satellite into orbit and the first thing
they said is hey we're taking pictures
of the Pentagon and the White House and
US nuclear installations we don't know
if they're bluffing but either way the
US and their allies are pretty pissed
but North Korea is just like hey we have
a right to develop our weapon systems
just like you do United States this
comes at a time when North and South
Korea had just made this agreement to
like lessen tensions and not do things
like this but now both sides are
breaking their agreements there's an
escalation this happens all the time
with these two and this is just another
episode of it but this episode is
happening in space if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more